Okay cool so I want to talk to you all
about how you can take your packages to
New Frontiers with our open siiz R
universe so uh a little bit about me so
uh two years ago I had a lightning talk
at our studio Global about my first
package which was a huge milestone for
me so I come from
psychology I come from psychology like
very is like we do some coding to do our
stats and our uh and our stuff but
there's like no formal training so
getting an r package out there that was
a huge deal for me and my package is
about plotting brains in
ggplot um this is so much fun to work on
and it uses simple features for those
who know about that so it's basically a
math but instead of the globe it's your
brain um it makes me very happy um so so
there's two parts of this package it's
ggplot 2 package with simple features
and there's a second part with plotly
and like a threedimensional swiv brain
very very fun um it loves it when we
want to put that online um so these
packages for this package at that point
lived only on GitHub uh because I did
not have the headspace or understanding
of how to get it on cran and we want our
packages on cran right like
I wanted to be an art developer so to be
that I needed to have a package on Crown
like I couldn't just have it on GitHub
and why do we want our packages on cran
now that's because that's where like
everyone else is getting their packages
from that's where users expect the
packages come they don't have like a
mental model necessarily about where the
packages are coming from they're coming
from cran you do install packages
they're coming from
cran so I want them there but like
getting them
there that is work um that is a lot of
work um so I had this package it had
this stuff and it like I was working on
my code getting it ready for
cron and I hit this roadblock my package
is too big there's a 5 megabyte
limit there's a lot of data Behind These
plots uh and I was struggling so the
first thing iiz oh I split it up in two
and I don't I don't no longer have one
package to get on cran I have two
packages to get on cran right okay but I
did the work and I got them both on
there and I'm super
[Laughter]
proud now a magic thing happened when
this package went from living on C on
GitHub to living on cran and that is all
the user installation problems just
poofed
away like before I would have like
issues constantly with people like it's
not installing it's not installing and
I'm like I don't know why cuz I'm not a
developer like I don't I don't
necessarily understand what's behind
this but cran just fixed all of that but
the thing
is you know how you have different Maps
like okay so the globe like the map
itself is the is the same but you can
kind of split the world up in different
ways depending on what you want to look
at by continents by country political
borders like geographical landmarks
whatever we do the same with the brain
don't think like neuroscientists we're
not like the brain is one thing though
it's so many features and everyone works
on like their own versions of all of
these features there's so many of them
um I I have like I think we have about
about 30 requests right now for new what
we call atlases and we have 20 already
and all of this all of these are over
five megabytes they will never go on
cran I cannot get them there unless I
like completely figure out how to get
away from the size of
them and all of these have issues with
installation and it's frustrating for me
and it's frustrating for my users
because I have no idea how to help them
I don't have an overview of what is
making this installation not
working
so what the hell does cran do that makes
this work I just dived into it I need to
figure out why why cran installations
work and I got to learn about binaries
now now
binaries are a thing I know nothing
about but I'm still going to try to
explain it to
you so imagine you're like these two R
users and you want to connect to this
you want to get to this star which is
the package you want to go
to so when you're what we're calling
compiling from Source you know once in a
while you write install packages blah
blah and it goes oh there is no binary
available do you want to compile from
source and you go yeah sure I need this
package compile from source and it does
like all of this stuff and you don't
know what it is and hopefully that's
going to work and you're going to be
happy and you get your package you're
like following this map you're here
you're G to go there you're following
all the steps you're getting there great
and then another user comes along their
OS is something else so they're starting
their Journey from another place so they
need to do something else there's
another road map for them to get there
and what if you're in Uncharted
Territory like you're on an OS that we
don't we don't know how to get you to
this place compile from Source
failed that is what my users are
struggling with so why so what are
binaries so binaries circumvent this
entire thing I love sci-fi so for me
they're like a wormhole so like it's a
pre-built thing like you know where you
are you know where you're going and you
just like there's a rift in SpaceTime
and you just get there that's what the
binary does like it just gets you there
awesome so when you have your package on
GitHub you have no binaries it's all
compiling from source which makes all of
the madness it's awesome for me easy I
just get my code up there just get it to
pass like the most important checks of
our Command so that it
installs but it can be hard for the user
because the binaries are not there crown
is awesome because it's easy for the
users binaries are there there's vetting
there's checking like Joe was just
talking about like there's this whole
infrastructure around it that makes it
work for the users but it is so much
work for me um and I'm not a full-time
developer I'm a scientist so um I need
something like in the
middle and like two months after I had
that lightning talk our open side comes
with their our universe the r universe
is a piece of software
magic that you cannot believe so jmes
who's the one who is behind this at our
openai he's a magician this stuff is so
good so it makes like its own little
cran like
server but without the vetting and stuff
but it works just like cran there's no
curation you design your own you put the
packages you want in there you get your
own universe and it's kind of organized
through like you user or organizations
through like uh GitHub gitlab bit bucket
stuff like that it's quite easy to
connect to so let's have a look so this
is my GT segr
Universe uh with some of the packages
that are in this universe and there's a
couple of things we want to look at
number one this is the main package you
see the little green ribbon that's
because it's on cray
so so you get this nice little thing if
your package is on cra and our universe
will detect it and it gives you this
lovely ribbon and you can go yay um but
the really exciting part is this part
over
here which is telling me that for our
version 4.3 and our version 4.2 I have
binaries for both Windows and Mac and
like this is the most magic thing I know
because the binaries are there I don't
have to think about them anymore like I
don't need to understand what they are
other than the wormhole and um it is
just working and once
this came into
place I don't have installation issues
anymore like it's just working it is
Magic and you know when you have your
package on GitHub you have to you have
to install either the dev tools or the
the remote package and then you have to
use like the special special install
function to get the blah blah notice
this piece of code this is all you need
to install from this univers you just
have to plug in that I want you to look
in this universe for packages that I'm
looking for and in this case I'm asking
to install the main GG package um it
will look for it first in the ggse
universe it will find
it and then for all the dependencies
it's going to jump to the next because I
don't have those in my universe like
there's are way too many it's just going
to jump to the next which is uh a crown
mirror super simple I just have that in
my read me now
don't have to think about
it so why would you want to have your
package on the our universe so you might
like me have all of these packages that
are huge and even if they weren't huge
I'm like not completely convinced that
like the cran team would be super happy
if I start flooding it with like brain
Atlas packages it's extremely Niche and
there's a lot of them and they keep like
it's just like
exploding um you might have learner
tutorial
like and you're giving it to your
students and you need them to run stuff
and they're not installing again
binaries they're going to install easily
uh you might have Dev versions that you
also want to distribute with binaries
because again it's going to install
easily or you might want to collect
packages for your company or your lab uh
so you have like a common ground of like
where your uh packages live and it
doesn't have to be packages you have
made you can put other packages into the
Universe um from other people if you
want to lock them down or like I had um
so one of these packages that I'm going
to talk to about about soon uh dependent
on than another Neuroscience r package
that had a bug at some point and I could
go back to my R universe and say I want
you to depend on the previous version of
this package because that makes my
univers work again until they fix the
bug so I could fix it without like
actually fixing it
um now a thing I noticed when I was
setting up this universe was
that in the beginning it was in a kind
of disorganized stage because these
packages this whole ecosystem comes from
a large European research project I was
on called life brain and we we had
several packages come out of life brain
that were not brain related they were
stats related or something else and like
my packages were
like it it was making all these other
packages less visible and it was kind of
cluttering it up and it also uh the
Neuroscience people weren't necessarily
interested in these other packages some
of them who are more alike as social
science
related so I realized like I I I should
probably switch things up a bit um so
because GitHub is quite easy when you're
an academic because you get free stuff
uh I just made a new organization
specifically for these packages and I
only did that because of the r universe
so that I could get like one unified
Universe for all of the packages for
this site
live uh and because they're now all
collected in the same spot it means that
it's also easier for me to start getting
contributions because I just include
them into this organization it's not
tied to my
like Horizon Europe project it's tied to
just this contribution from the
community and because like all the
installation issues poofed uh by this
thing I could use that headspace to
start making a package that would enable
people to make their own atlases so that
I didn't have to make it for everyone
because I just don't have time for that
um so um so I made this other package
that contains tooling to create your own
GG Atlas it's a monster of a thing
because it calls a lot of like other
neuros sign stuff and it's like uh Jesus
but it's there and it works for me and
it has worked for a couple of other
people and and I'm I'm excited to see
that it is being
used so
and so the r Universe has a lot of extra
stuff going on as well so in this like
extra package that I have we it its
first iteration also contained a data
set a table in this case uh about where
all of the atlases that were compatible
with these this Suite
lived with the idea that they would
probably not be in the same spot because
our universe didn't exist when I started
on this I had started on this before
that um and we would need to like
manually update this every time like a
new eist came in
and that is
like it's a bit of work and I'm like um
I prefer things to be a bit more
automatic than that uh a good friend on
M once said I became a developer because
I'm lazy um I think that's kind of true
for me too so anything that can just
happen automatically I'm very very fond
of and through um the our universe I
could do that so now instead of a tibble
I just have a bit of code in a function
uh that just looks that call calls the
ropi API and asks hey can you list all
the packages in this universe and it
does and I just make it into a
tibble that's it that is it it's I'm so
happy you have no idea
um uh it is it's it's such a powerful
piece and like I'm not going to cover
everything that um it does it does so
many things it's the API it will render
your documentation it will give you like
pages to uh browse through it will like
and and I know there's a lot of things
going on in the
pipeline so while we do love cran for
its consistency for the fact that uh
it's something we can connect to it is
safe it is there it does a lot of magic
for
us we can all expand our
Horizons by a lot
by using the r Universe because it is
such a powerful piece of tool and I
thoroughly thoroughly believe if you
have a package on
GitHub you should have a package in our
open siiz our
universe
thanks thanks so much M um Tyler could
you come up and go ahead and get plugged
in here um you have just time for maybe
one question here uh are there any
advantages installing the package from
our universe versus crayon if it's
available on both um so in my case like
um advantages and disadvantages it kind
of depends on the person that has set up
the the r universe so in my case if
you're getting it so GG say which is
both on cran and on our universe if
you're getting it from the r Universe
you're getting the development version
if you're getting it from cran you're
getting the released version and I know
several people who do it that way it's
not necessarily the way it's set up but
it might be so the version on Crown
might be uh more stable to use in a
sense
um so I think that's more of a
preference and probably like ask the
developer which version is the preferred
one yeah yeah um and then just real
quick have you received any push back
from your users who were like no I only
want it from crant or are they just are
they just happy from wherever it comes
from oh no they're just so happy that it
exists no like so our Neuroscience is
like like the hugest community in the
world so um when if something installs
they're just going to be happy so if
it's on our universe like cran Universe
GitHub doesn't matter if it is installs
and they can use it they're happy uh and
that's an amazing place to be yeah let's
give What mo one more round of applause
yeah